anyway joining us now with a full report
investigative reporter Fox News
contributor Sarah Carter Sarah it was uh
Beyond revealing today
was Sean and you and I have been
sounding the alarm for years the
political rot at America's most powerful
institutions is severe that's what we
learned today liberal high-ranking
unelected bureaucrats from D.C
constantly put their own political
beliefs over that of the people they
claim to serve this is especially true
at the FBI and doj for example parents
voicing their concern about the woke
agenda in schools were literally labeled
as domestic terrorists far right
American men were broadly characterized
as the greatest threat to the United
States
Mar-A-Lago was rated in search of a few
documents from Trump's own presidency
high level and low-level Trump
associates also faced early morning
raids perjury traps and other aggressive
tactics that were once reserved for
violent criminals we learned last night
that 140 Americans faced possible
charges for merely riding a bus to
Trump's January 6th rally meanwhile
rioters who breach the capitol on
January 6th were punished with lengthy
prison sentences but the far-left rioter
Sean in Portland Oregon who attempted to
burn a federal courthouse to the ground
every night for several months faced
almost no legal consequences at all the
majority of the charges were dropped
completely dropped Sean we could go on
and on and on and on but for some reason
Democrats fought tooth and nail against
this committee maybe that's because the
bias and weaponization always cuts one
way as the saying goes sometimes people
don't want to hear the truth because
they don't want their Illusions
destroyed Sean you know Sarah 574 riots
summer of 2020 uh thousands of cops
injured billions in property damage
dozens of dead Americans there was no
committee January 6 committee what did
NBC News finally report that in fact
they had intelligence really good
intelligence uh in the lead up to
January 6th and our law enforcement
didn't act on it that didn't make the
final report autograph for money by Adam
kinziger and Liz Cheney and Company
because that didn't fit their
predetermined outcome just to bash
Donald Trump and that would have helped
our government prevent anything like
that from happening again it's sad but
anyway Sarah Carter great report tonight
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else